so I've been making a lot of videos
lately but I feel like I need to catch
up like I'm not updated enough and do
all these videos that have been
requested for a long time even on my
older channel so I just want to like do
them see you guys gonna be happy cuz I'm
here for I was born in 88 so I grew up
in the 90s most of these games are not
gonna be like please station 3 Xbox 360
they're gonna be some of the you know
more older games that I love from my
childhood perhaps this will give you an
idea what kind of gamer I actually am
this is my NES Nintendo Entertainment
System and it still works I tried to
make a top 10 but I couldn't think of 10
so I made a top 7 starting up at number
7 one that's generally on people's
number one Zelda Ocarina of Time the
video site called gamerankings calm
Zelda Ocarina of Time is listed as the
top reviewed game of all time courses on
the Nintendo 64 my favorite systems a
fantastic adventure game with so much
death way ahead of its time
all the Zelda games are fun but that is
definitely the best of the bunch at
number 6 super mario 64 i played that
game for weeks until I got all 120 stars
and I remember searching everywhere for
that last star and when I had 119 stars
I was like freaking out I was like oh my
gosh I'm almost there I mom was there
it's just a really great game that was
one of the very first games to showcase
the Nintendo 64 was ability to have 3d
environments T n64 was the biggest jump
of graphics ever from Super NES Nintendo
64 all game systems after that have
logical jumps and graphics and now it's
they're just getting better and better
but from Super NES Nintendo 64 people
were like pooping their pants I mean it
was like oh my god
and number five we have one of the
greatest first-person shooters ever made
Goldeneye 64
I played Goldeneye all the time I
remember being in school I think it was
early middle school yeah and I would be
like in class and I'm just be thinking
about Goldeneye like we're gonna home
play : I got home play Goldeneye gold my
gold my gold my gold my gold my gold
mine
kogasa and number four we have the Super
Smash Brothers series yes all three each
one of them excellent and each one of
them consecutively getting better with
their release all the way from super
smash 64 to two purse manage melee to
supersonic brawl they are the greatest
multiplayer games I have ever played I
can get together with my friends and we
will just play that game and we were
like we're just like screaming and
sweating and everything it's fantastic
the only really problem with the Super
Smash game is that if you're just
playing by yourself it's nowhere near as
fun as if you played a whole bunch of
friends you have to be careful because
you can have a whole night playing those
games they are so much fun at number
three we have the Metroid Prime trilogy
I adore these games it's like a sci-fi
Alien Shooter type adventure the main
character is Samus one of the things I
love about it is that it's a girl I
think it's really cool I probably like
the third one the most actually but the
first one is pretty nostalgic for me the
second one's definitely my least
favorite but the third one introduces a
really cool motion-detecting
first-person shooter controller system
with the week so innovative and very
very entertaining all of them are
excellent games my number two is my pick
for the most underrated game of all time
jet force Gemini
I've gotten literally years of
entertainment I jump for stamina I
played it I've beaten it then I go back
like a year later and I play it again it
has my favorite video game score of all
time by Robin Beland look that up it's
on YouTube it was made by rare where the
country the bed Goldeneye and Donkey on
64 perfect dark you know all these
excellent games banjo-kazooie
it came up pretty much the same time the
donkey phone came out so it was really
overshadowed by that and it was well I
think kind of got lost in translation a
little bit it is an excellent game that
has pretty good reviews and it's a
really good really fun game my number
one pick for greatest game of all time
is actually four games the Metal Gear
Solid quadrilogy now I know as you guys
are watching this you're like man is
Nintendo fanboy like the agenda then
sick people or in kendo game I never won
pick is from PlayStation so hopefully
that makes you happy all four of these
games are incredible I have never been
more emotionally attached to a storyline
in my life the first time that I played
Metal Gear Solid was the PlayStation
version the first kind of beat Metal
Gear Solid the very next day I picked it
up again and I beat the entire game in
one day a second time lead character of
Solid Snake has so much depth all of his
background has so much depth all of the
games have such an emotional depth
that's the greatest thing about those
games that you become invested in them
they are so much fun and or than of your
Solid games Colonel what do I do to get
out of this situation press the select
button snake select button what are you
talking about there's no select button
are you crazy
it's the little tiny rectangular button
on your controller snake I'm not pulling
it controller colonel I'm in the war
field you idiot I always thought that
was funny how in Metal Gear Solid it was
so serious and obvious when the colonel
would be like snake press the square
button and snake is like where's the
square button it's funny so thanks so
much for watching this vid I hope you
liked it I know you can tell I'm
obviously a huge Nintendo 64 fan those
are some of the greatest times in my
life actually playing those games it's
just a lot of good memories and so you
know how it is you know the good old
days